chapter 9 consciousness
consciousness is never static or
complete but is an
unending process of movement and
unfoldment
david bowm diversity in oneness
is the mathematics of the infinite
sri aurobindo
diversity in oneness no more profound
thought has ever been uttered
consciousness is both one symphony
and the individual unique artists
that play different instruments and
melodies
imagine planet earth like a sports game
or
mmo rpg massive multiplayer online role
playing game
being played by eight billion
fans people in lagos
have a different perspective than
shanghai
or london unique angles
on what's happening locally and globally
think about it like calculus we have an
integration of eight billion
perspectives
into one consciousness plus a unique
differentiation for each of us
individuating with our
actualization of contributory gifts
differentiation
is realizing the 0.1 percent genetic
difference between
humans in gift actualization
integration is embodying the 99.9
genetic similarity between humans in
the ocean of being
the dress the one eye
of the world that looks out from every
creature
arthur schopenhauer
we are the same subject in different
timelines
interacting with itself bernardo castro
in 2015 our planet experienced one of
the most
profound things that has ever happened
to human civilization
and we just bypassed it like nothing the
deeper meaning
of the dress is to get us to understand
to not
kill another person for seeing a
different truth
to coexist peacefully
practice right now switching between
closing one of your eyes two
perspectives
same observer
have two painters ever seen
the same landscape in the same way
we must create more examples like the
dress
where perception cannot flip-flop
between the options
like it can in the classical visual
necker cube
ruben vase duck rabbit or auditory
yanny laurel to drive home coexistence
in seeing many true perspectives
simultaneously
while in conversation practice taking
the view
of the one consciousness looking at what
is happening
from multiple perspectives
work your way up to residing
in the view of holding all 8 billion
perspectives
simultaneously mirrors
of being
the dress should have prompted a much
longer
societal contemplation into the nature
of perception and reality
we need to recognize and learn from
monumental discoveries like these
identity your intellect is
always a slave of your identity sarguru
al-wujud the unity of existence
slash being sufi metaphysics
a clear indicator of spiritual awakening
is the porosity of a human
are you identified with just your body
trapped with a box around your head
or do you realize that every one of your
20 000
daily inhales of o2 comes from the
photosynthesis
of phytoplankton and trees do you
realize the water we drink today is the
same water dinosaurs drink
when exactly does the bite of the apple
become you when you're chewing it
when it is being digested by your
stomach
when it delivers energy to yourselves
how porous are you to the ocean of
existence we reside in or are you
heavily attached to your feelings of
separation
this is a main upstream route of our
maladies
attachment to ego
spiritual people frequently talk about
expanding your consciousness
but forget to use these most scientific
examples
right under our noses which validate the
unity of existence
being the more we
understand our source and how mother
earth
sustains us the less we'll be willing
to destroy our home and the faster
we'll execute sustainable long-term
growth
architectures that are harmonious with
nature
porosity is scale invariant cells
communicate via a porous
lipid bilayer ecosystems share nutrients
across
underground mycorrhizae countries
ship 90 percent of all world trade in
barges
across oceans when humans evolve their
consciousness towards
transpersonal and non-dual states
porosity is a natural and gorgeous
feeling of truth
you